the secret life of pets might
technically be considered a kid's fill
but the story is so much fun that it
appeals to grownups as well of course
watching a movie as an adult isn't the
same experience as watching it as a kid
here are things that only adults notice
in the secret life of pets there's no
doubt that katie loves max but she's not
exactly the most responsible pet parent
we met a few years ago and boy let me
tell you we got along right away early
in the story we can see her biking with
Max who is riding unsecured in a basket
attached to the front of her bike it's
me and Katie Katie and me us against the
world
when you want to ride a bike with your
dog in real life they should always be
safely harnessed in the baskets this
will keep them secure so they don't
bounce out if you hit a bump in the road
and speaking of unexpected circumstances
Katie should obviously be wearing her
helmets too I know this'll take some
getting used to but simple but I think
it's gonna be a great thing in the long
haul Duke is a huge dog but he's also
just an outgoing Papa who just wants to
make friends with his new roommate max
he excitedly greets his new canine pal
although he isn't given the most welcome
of greetings in return okay it's gonna
be all right Duke
in real life introducing two dogs to
each other for the first time doesn't
always go that smoothly according to the
animal Humane Society it's best to keep
them leashed at first and allow them to
slowly get to know each other they also
should not be left at home alone
together right away at least not in the
same room Katie should have either put
them in separate rooms all crated them
which at the very least would have
prevented max from creating a mess in
the apartment
welcome to the underbelly brothers how
much defense
the primary antagonists throughout the
film are the flushed pets a motley crew
of animals that have been abandoned by
their owners they make for a well
organized group of militant animals who
are understandably angry with humans for
how they've been treated only accepting
Maxx and Duke after they claim to have
killed their owners this is coming to
Brooklyn and it's got what teeth and a
Cottontail the group is loosely modeled
after the Black Power movement of the
1960s and 70s which has drawn some
criticism since the flushed pets are
portrayed as the movies bad guys and
their very real problems are used as
comedic relief Jason Johnson a professor
of political science and political
editor of the route wrote that the use
of racial stereotypes in the film is
problematic and that they quote turn
black protests and death into a joke
when Max and Duke go missing their
faithful friends come to the rescue they
band together determined to sniff out
their missing pals and bring them home
before Katy even realizes they're gone
they need some help though and one of
the animals they enlist is a predatory
Hawk who lives on the roof of their
apartment building I can see for miles
if you let me out I'll find your friend
but in real life the city has some
pretty strict laws governing what kind
of pets residents can keep prohibiting
them from owning wild and illegal
animals on the list of banned pets are
not just Hawks but also other predatory
birds such as eagles falcons vultures
and owls like most dogs max and Duke
love food when they enter a sausage
factory in search of a snack they eat so
much they fall into a food coma and doze
off into a daydream that's basically
doggy heaven to kids this scene is a
feel-good number with a couple of cute
pups adults though will recognize that
the song the sausages are singing is
from the musical Grease the iconic
number we go together is one that might
not be too familiar to kids but is sure
to strike a chord of nostalgia with
grownups co-director Chris Renault told
Entertainment Weekly it just felt like
the song
it perfectly truly it's the kind of
scene people either love or think what
the heck was that I like to think the I
love it outweighs the what the heck was
that crowd I mean this may be the
sausage talking but you're okay
right back at you man check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]